comment ça va très bien vous écrivez
votre biographie actuellement oui alors
comment ça se passe ça fait pas mal de
temps que ça dure le buteur s'impatiente
oui ouais je faisais du malin oui à
raconter des trucs mais vous n'êtes pas
de votre papa en d'aviation génial ouais
le père de jeanne s'il avait la closed
doors oui avant la cloche d'or ouais
voilà voilà
et la maman de jal était danseuse aux
folies bergères c'est une anglaise qui
le gams voilà je voulais parler de tout
ça ah ben bien sien ce génial et enfin
ouais vous séparer de votre mariage
aussi des tous les six gravement cinq
jours du mariage
bah oui gel coiffant le cul c'est le
lendemain j'ai parlé tout truffaut louis
malle orson welles luis bunuel tout ça
oui ben je vois si j'oublie quelqu'un je
pourrais m'adresser à vous vous allez
parler de william friedkin
bien sûr c'est le seul qui vous ai
jamais demandé en mariage il avait
épousé finalement en fait oui ouais ma
foi et cardin faisait paraître cardan
aussi oui mais c'est génial ce soir
consistoire en 2005
en 2005 vous viendrait ici un à vraiment
je vous adore merci plan c'est vrai
alors c'est une idole aujourd'hui un
jeune m'a vraiment vous êtes encensé par
tout le monde est devenu un touché en
panique
on va voir justement on va vous obliger
à dire du mal de vous être négative on
va quand même on va faire l'interview
brûlons nos idoles
hors jeu de mots dans quel mauvais film
avez vous joué il ya mme saint germain
des prés avec berthomieu voilà
regarderai le feu dans quel film vous
trouvez-vous très mauvaise un film de
jacques de ville d'angers où lui et le
titre qui se passait dans un bar tu
t'étais un seul décor
le pasteur michel de logiciels de bi
quels films avez vous accepté uniquement
pour l'argent jeune femme venait nous
amène le film de martin ritt qui
s'appelait cinq femmes marquées en
français mais j ai gagné j'ai payé mes
impôts j'ai dû me raser la tête
léger gagner l'amitié de silvana mangano
et j'ai appris l'italien grâce à elle et
je vous ai déjà voté à droite n'ayant
jamais combien d'hommes avaient trompé
pas mal pas mal je vous ai déjà dénoncer
quelqu'un jamais est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles de brigitte bardot non
plus quelques caprices de stars
faites-vous régulièrement voyage avec
mes oreilles et ça gêne personne est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait semblant de
téléphoner pour pas donner d'argent sdf
est-ce que vous avez déjà appelé une
ambulance pour circuler plus vite dans
pareille annonce un camion de pompiers
est ce que vous trouvez pas j'aime que
catherine deneuve a beaucoup grossi ces
derniers temps quand même car j'ai pas
n'est pas la bonne actrice très peu
est-ce que vous avez déjà refusé de
donner de l'argent à une organisation
humanitaire
oui à quelle franchise nous abordent
entre aniane tu vois comment elle répond
mais emmanuel tu vois comment elle
réellement franche du collier au moins
bah moi aussi j'aime pas du tout mais
pas du tout qui s'était le plus con dans
la ferme
ah ah il y avait un concours à
jeanne nous rester avec nous ouais c'est
un petit peu dur à vivre
voilà la suite c'est luis fernandez